ouais en fait ce qui nous dérange c'est
les deux spots en face là ils sont pas
allumés
d'habitude bien pendant que Marc règle
les
problèmes de surluminosité je vous
propose de démarrer euh si tout le monde
est est attentif d'abord je voudrais à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous vous
souhaiter une une excellente année
2024 euh plein de bonnes choses pour
vous et ceux qui vous sont chers et puis
pour notre commission j'espère
évidemment de que nous continueront à
travailler efficacement au service de de
notre pays et comme nous avons su le
faire ces dernières années à à avancer
Dieu sait si les sujets sont nombreux
donc je pense que nous n'en manquerons
pas donc bonne année à vous et
et donc aujourd'hui on est très heureux
de pouvoir
accueillir pour une première audition la
première audition de la matinée madame
Céline Pagon qui donc est chercheur et
responsable des activités Japon au
centre Asie Indo-Pacifique de l'Institut
français des relations internationales
l'ri et donc nous vous entendons
aujourd'hui sur la nouvelle posture
stratégique du Japon dans
l'Indo-Pacifique qui est l'implication
pour la France et ça tombe plutôt bien
puisque nous avons vous le savez un
rapport ENF une mission d'information
sur le Japon qui permettra de poursuivre
la mission d'information que nous avons
fait l'an dernier sur l'Indopacifique en
se concentrant l'an dernier sur la
partie plus au sud qui concernait
essentiellement par des déplacements en
tout cas l'Indonésie et la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
alors donc il s'agit donc de prolonger
je le disais à l'instant de le travail
d'information que nous avions entamé
l'an dernier par notre rapport sur la
France dans l'in paacifique en l'ouvrant
cette fois au Japon un pays qui se
trouve au cœur des tensions de plus en
plus forte avec à son Nord la Russie à
l'ouest la Corée du Nord et au Sud la
Chine et Taïwan évidemment
certains attribuent d'ailleurs au Japon
la paternité du
conceptindo-pacifique puisque le Premier
ministre shinzoabe avait prononcé ce
terme en 2007 lors d'une visite en Inde
précisément dans le but de concevoir une
stratégie de défense contre son imposant
voisin chinois pour nous éclairer sur
donc les visions respectives du Japon et
de la France dans l'Indo-Pacifique nous
avons je viens de le dire le plaisir
d'accueillir Céline Pagon qui donc
chercheur responsable d'activité au
Japon sur le Japon au centre àifri donc
madame vous avez récemment publié
plusieurs articles consacrés à ce sujet
un premier article intitulé nouvelle
stratégie de sécurité et de défense au
Japon comme mon diton dton V au japonais
en japonais c'est original euh dans
lequel vous expliquez que le Japon vient
d'enteriner un changement d'air dans sa
posture de sécurité et de défense à
l'instar d'un tournant engagé du
tournant engagé par l'Allemagne après
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie et
dans le second article vous appelez la
France dans l'Indo-Pacifique à adopter
une posture stratégique pragmatique et
nous serons donc intéressés par vous
recommander nation nous avons appris le
weekend dernier l'élection du nouveau
président de Taïwan réputé pour sa ligne
indépendantiste ce qui ne devrait pas
forcément apaiser les discours et les
actes toujours plus menaçants de la
Chine vous nous direz comment le Japon
envisage la guerre hybride qui se joue
actuellement dans le détroit de Taiwan
et comment selon vous il réagirait en
cas de déclenchement d'une véritable
d'un véritable conflit armé je rappelle
que les îles Nipon les plus méridionales
ne sont qu'à une centaine de kilomètres
de Taïwan par ailleurs nous avons noté
l'augmentation de 17 % du budget de la
défense japonais qui dépassera les 50
milliards d'euros avec d'importants
investissements en terme de défense
antimissile à l'égard de la Corée du
Nord de construction navale et de
missiles de croisière on parle de 400
missiles Tom awok acquisè auprès des
États-Unis et il ne s'agit donc plus
d'un budget répondant à une doctrine de
pure autodéfense comme l'étaaiit jusqu'à
présent les forces japonaises mais bien
de contre-attaque le Japon est-il prêt à
cette mutation et à entrer en guerre au
côté des Américains voire des
Sud-Coréens s'il le fallait enfin une
information semble être passée largement
sous les radars de l'actualité il s'agit
du partenariat d'exception entre la
France et le Japon conclu à la fin
d'année 2023 sur les enjeux de sécurité
économique pourrait-on aller plus loin
et notamment en matière de coopération
d'armement et de défense ce sont
quelques interrogations sur lesquelles
vous pourrez revenir dans vos propos
liminires et à l'issue évidemment de
nous aurons l'occasion d'échanger par
des questions des réponses avec les
membres de la commission je vous donne
donc la parole je rappelle que
l'audition est captée elle sera donc
diffusée sur le site du Sénat je vous
laisse donc la parole pour une quinzaine
vingtaine de minutes et puis ensuite
nous passerons aux question réponse
merci beaucoup je vous laisse la
parole merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité à
m'exprimer devant vous ce matin et de
participer aux travaux de la commission
alors pourquoi parler du Japon
aujourd'hui d'abord le Japon vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président est un
pays précurseur de ce qu'on appelle
l'Indo-Pacifique la stratégie pour un
Indo-Pacifique libre et ouvert a été
effectivement évoqué et lancé
formellement par le Premier ministre
shinzoabé en 2016 et cette approche a
bien sûr fait Flores depuis le Japon est
un des partenaires stratégiques de la
France dans
l'Indo-Pacifique ensuite vous l'avez
également évoqué on observe une une
transformation de la posture de défense
japonaise ces dernières années avec des
décisions
historique que l'on a pu comparer donc
au Titon 22 cette ce changement de
doctrine de l'Allemagne enfin le Japon
est un acteur et un partenaire majeur
dans le contexte de la rivalité
sino-américaine il est en première ligne
littéralement face à Pékin qui est aussi
son premier partenaire économique c'est
également l'allié le plus proche des
États-Unis en Asie je rappelle qu'il y a
toujours 50000 soldats américains qui
sont euh donc au Japon sur sur des bases
euh donc ce matin j'organiserai mon
propos en trois points pour refléter euh
vos euh vos points d'intérêt euh d'abord
j'expliciterai les priorités
stratégiques sécuritaires euh du Japon
ensuite j'expliquerai comment le Japon
s'adapte à cet environnement stratégique
de plus en plus dégradé et je reviendrai
en final sur les spécificités et les
enjeux du partenariat
franco-japonais alors les priorités
stratégiques du Japon vous avez euh une
carte devant vous et quand on regarde la
carte c'est assez évident ça saute aux
yeux le les les les problématiques
sécuritaires les priorités sécuritaire
se trouve directement dans le voisinage
du Japon donc l'archipel japonais est
constitué de milliers d'îles euh qui et
il s'étend donc de tout au nord euh
d'okido euh où il voisine avec la Russie
avec la Russie avec lesquels d'ailleurs
il y a toujours eu un différent
territorial autour de ce que les
Japonais appellent les territ terire du
Nord et que les les Russes appellent les
couril Sud donc qui
est qui est désigné sur la carte en
rouge donc ça c'est tout au nord tout au
sud nous allons jusqu'à l'archipel des
des luku
Okinawa on va même jusqu'à l'archipel
Yayama vous voyez sur cette carte qui se
trouve effectivement qui a une centaines
de kilomètres des côtes
tawanaises alors le Japon a des
différents territoriaux vous pouvez le
constater non seulement avec la Russie
mais aussi avec la Corée du Sud autour
des îles Takeshima dogdo qui sont sous
contrôle coréen mais et surtout avec la
Chine autour des îles Senkaku dioyu qui
sont sous contrôle japonais revendiqué
par Pékin qui se trouve à 300 km des
côtes chinoises 150 km des côtes
tawanaises et qui sont un lieu de
tension important depuis des années
enfin le Japon fait face à deux États
autoritaires révisionnistes la Chine et
la Russie et un état totalitaire la
Corée du Nord tous trois doté de l'arme
nucléaire donc le Japon est confronté à
la perspective d'un triple front à la
fois autoritaire et
nucléaire donc on le voit l'archipel
nippon évolue dans un environnement de
sécurité complexe dangereux et qui s'est
très largement dégradé ces dernières
années d'abord la Chine donc qui fait
peser une menace directe sur l'intégrité
territoriale japonaise depuis 12 ans la
Chine effectue des incursions maritimes
et aériennes très fréquentes autour des
îles Saku pour contester la souveraineté
et le contrôle japonais et c'est une
situation particulièrement difficile à
gérer pour le Japon car ces incursions
ne sont pas le fait de bateau de guerre
chinois mais de bateau des gardescôte VO
voire même des bateaux de pêcheurs donc
cela crée ce qu'on appelle une situation
de de zone grise en tout cas une
stratégie de guerre hybride qui sont
particulièrement déli à gérer parce
qu'il faut opposer des limites sans pour
autant escalader la situation en
envoyant des forces armées sur le
théâtre ces dernières années on note une
nette montée des tensions dans le
détroit de Taïwan depuis août 2002 avec
2022 pardon avec la visite de Nancy
Pelosi à Taïwan à ce moment-là on a vu
les forces chinoises procéder à des
exercices majeurs avec des tir balle
réelle et une simulation de blocus dans
le détroit de Taïwan à cette occasion
des missiles chinois ont été tirés dans
la zone économique exclusive du Japon le
Japon serait donc nécessairement impacté
par une crise dans le détroit de Taïwan
d'abord vous l'avez compris par de par
la proximité avec les les territoires
propres du Japon mais aussi parce que
plus de 20000 Japonais vivent à taiïwan
donc cela poserait nécessairement la
question de l'évacuation des
ressortissants japonais enfin parce
qu'en tant qu'allier des États-Unis il
constitue une cible il y a la moitié des
troupes américaines donc qui sont au
Japon qui sont sur des bases à Okinawa
donc vraiment tout au sud tout au sud de
l'archipel japonais très proche de
Taiwan mais aussi en tant caliier des
États-Unis le Japon devrait apporter un
soutien aux forces américaines un
soutien qui pourrait être à minima
logistique mais qui pourrait aller
jusqu'à apporter
une protection une défense des et
défendre les les les forces américaines
si elles étaient attaquées dans
l'environnement du Japon donc la Chine
est clairement identifiée aujourd'hui
comme le risque de sécurité numéro 1
pour l'archipel
Nipon la seconde menace régionale pour
le Japon c'est la Corée du Nord son
programme nucléaire et balistique le
Japon peut être impacté par l'ensemble
des missiles nord-coréens de courte
moyenne et longue portée et d'ailleurs
le le nord de l'archipel en particulier
he okïo l'île deokaido a été survolé à
plusieurs reprises par ses engins et des
missiles sont tombés également à
plusieurs reprises dans la zone
économique exclusive du Japon alors on
sait que la Corée du Nord désormais état
nucléaire de facto a progressé ces
dernières années en terme de
sophistication des vecteurs de
miniaturisation des charges nucléaires
sans compter les attaques euh de Cyb
sécurité alors aujourd'hui la Corée du
Nord Est euh semble encouragée par son
rapprochement avec la Russie et euh vous
vous l'avez constaté ces derniers jours
devient de plus en plus menaçante en
tout cas voilà dans sa rhétorique et ses
actions vis-à-vis de son voisin du Sud
euh mais évidemment ça pourrait créer un
une crise régionale donc la Corée du
Nord reste pour le Japon qualifié de
menace
imminente troisème menace régionale la
Russie
jusqu'en 2022 en réalité la Russie n'est
pas perçue comme une menace le
gouvernement de l'ancien Premier
ministre shinzoabé donc shinzoabé est
resté a eu un mandat vraiment très très
long euh au Japon entre 2012 et 2020 il
est été Premier ministre et il a pu
imprimer sa marque sur le pays mais
shinzoabé lui cherchait plutôt à se
rapprocher de Vladimir Poutine pour
conclure un traité de paix euh ce traité
de paix n'a toujours pas été signé hein
depuis la fin de de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et il a été empêché par le
contentieux territorial donc des coursî
Sud euh ce faisant shinzoabé espérait
notamment stratégiquement ralentir aussi
le rapprochement entre la Chine et la
Russie toutefois malgré les les efforts
importants du Premier ministre japonais
euh le Japon n'a jamais rien obtenu de
la part de la Russie aucune concession
et après l'agression russe en Ukraine
Tokyo a formellement abandonné sa
politique de maintendu pour s'aligner
sur la position de ses partenaires du
G7 dès lors les activités militaires
russes aux alentours de l'archipel dont
des incursions navales et aériennes
assez régulières sont considérées comme
je cite une forte préoccupation de
sécurité le Japon fait également face à
la coordination militaire sinorusse dans
la région avec la multiplication de
patrouilles aériennes communes et des
patrouilles navales avec la circon
navigation de l'archipel qui alarme de
plus en plus
Tokyo enfin et pour m'extraire un peu du
du de l'environnement régional immédiat
et pour bien comprendre la la
problématique sécuritaire du Japon je
souhaite rappeler la vulnérabilité et la
forte dépendance de l'archipel japonais
vis-à-vis des routes maritimes pour ses
approvisionnements euh le Japon n'est
pas doté de de de de ressources
naturelles propres donc il est
extrêmement dépendant que ce soit pour
sa sécurité alimentaire énergétique mais
évidemment plus globalement pour ces
échanges
commerciaux la préservation de la
liberté de navigation et la sécurisation
des routes maritimes et donc un enjeu
absolument vital pour le Japon cela
explique que le pays a par exemple
ouvert une base logistique à Djibouti en
2011 pour soutenir l'effort de ces
forces d'autodéfense qui participent aux
opérations de de lutte antipiraterie
dans le golfe d'Eden notamment au côté
de la mission européenne
Atalanta
alors comment le Japon s'adapte à cet
environnement stratégique de plus en
plus
hostile d'abord en investissant dans ses
propres capacités de défense puis en
investissant dans son alliance avec les
États-Unis mais aussi en remodelant son
environnement
stratégique alors je rappelle rapidement
le le contexte qui qui conditionne la
posture stratégique la posture de
défense du
Japon donc depuis 19 947 le Japon a une
constitution dite pacifiste l'article 9
de cette Constitution lui interdit en
effet d'entretenir des forces armées
régulières et de faire la
guerre donc au Japon il y a un ensemble
de normes politiques et légales qui ont
été mises en place depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale pour limiter
volontairement cette cette posture de
défense notamment avec l'interdiction
d'avoir des capacités offensives
l'interdiction de se doter d'armes
nucléaires l'interd ition d'exporter des
armes et des technologies de défense
pour autant le Japon donc sans armées
régulière a mis en place des force
d'autodéfense donc spécifiquement dédié
à la défense de l'archipel qui sont
contraintes du de de fait dans leur
mission et dans leur équipement
toutefois elle représente aujourd'hui un
budget non négligeable c'est autour du
du du 8e budget mondial et avec 260000
solld soldat qui la qui la
compose enfin l'archipel reste toujours
très dépendant de son alliance de
sécurité avec les
États-Unis en matière de renseignement
de détection précoce mais aussi en
matière donc de capacité offensive vous
l'avez compris on dit communément que
dans l'alliance
nipo-américaine le Japon joue un rôle de
bouclier de défense et que les
États-Unis joue le rôle de glave s'il y
avait une attaque ce sont les États-Unis
qui riposteraient le Japon bénéf ici
également du parapluie nucléaire
américain donc la dissuasion étendue les
États-Unis donc c'est c'est une une un
portrait que je vous brosse d'un pays
qui est dans une situation finalement
assez exceptionnelle et au Japon
beaucoup d'homm politique parle de de
situation même
anormale donc au cours de cette dernière
décennie on a on a assisté à une
normalisation de cette de cette posture
politico-militaire du Japon et même une
accélération de cette
normalisation afin de pouvoir que le que
le Japon puisse répondre à cet
environnement de sécurité de plus en
plus menaçant avec des outils
adéquates alors cette normalisation elle
a d'abord eu lieu sous le mandat de
shinzoab donc entre 2012 et 2020 qui en
avait fait sa priorité mais ça ça a
été continué sous ses successeurs
messieurs Suga et Kishida qui s'inscrit
vraiment dans la continuité euh de
Monsieur abbé avec deux avancées
particulièrement marquantes en
2014-2015 le Japon procède à une
réinterprétation de sa constitution qui
lui permet euh de pouvoir exercer de
manière extrêmement encadrée son droit à
l'autodéfense collective c'est-à-dire la
sa possibilité la possibilité pour les
forces japonaises de pouvoir porter
secours à un allié s'il est attaqué et
euh il abandonne également le principe
de non exportation des équipements et
technologies de défense donc le Japon à
partir de ce moment-là peut euh agir sur
le marché de l'armement
international deuxème avancée en
décembre 2022 beaucoup plus récemment
sous le gouvernement Kishida il y a des
nouveaux documents de de stratégiques
qui sont adoptés et là on voit une une
inflexion
significative de la posture de défense
japonaise cette inflexion s'appuie sur
un objectif de doublement du budget de
la défense japonaise en 5 ans on
considère que le le budget de la défense
est autour de de 1 % du du PIB donc on
arriverait autour de 2 % du PIB en
2027 et deuxième point cette cette
inflexion donc ça avalise pour la
première fois la mise en place d'une
capacité de contre-attaque pour le
Japon alors concernant le
budget
aujourd'hui le la Chine investit quatre
fois plus que le Japon dans sa défense
euh donc selon les les Japonais ça
incite à vraiment un effort très très
important de de rattrapage pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir se défendre et avoir une
une dissuasion de assez assez
importante donc le gouvernement Kishida
a décidé de s'affranchir d'une
convention politique qui date de 1976 et
qui plafonne le budget de défense à 1 %
du PIB il s'est aligné sur les
références de l'OTAN c'est c'est pas ce
n'est pas euh innocent et donc il s'est
engagé à atteindre 2 % du PIB euh et
mais pour autant euh je je je
souhaiterais nuancer un peu le son son
annonce en disant que ce n'est pas
vraiment strictement un doublement des
crédits de défense stricto censu le
gouvernement japonais va en effet
élargir l'assiette de calcul euh de son
budget de défense en y intégrant des
lignes budgétaires notamment dédiées au
garde-côte ce qui n'était pas le cas des
poissonss de retraite et euh et et
d'autres programmes par exemple pour
l'espace par ailleurs je souhaite
rappeler que le financement d'un tel
effffort budgétaire fait débat alors que
la dette au Japon atteint 260 % du
PIB concernant la capacité de
contre-attaque à nouveau le facteur
chinois est très important avec 300
missiles de croisière et plus de 1000
missiles balistique la Chine a
aujourd'hui les moyens de saturer le
système de défense antimissile japonais
qui a été mis en place dans les années
2000 d'abord avec la Corée du Nord en
tête donc maintenir une capacité de
dissuasion justifie donc aujourd'hui des
investissements dans des capacités de
contre-attaque qui doivent permettre de
frapper des bases ou des installations
ennemies donc Tokyo veut effectivement
tripler son arsenal d'interception et de
frappe et notamment vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président en faisant
l'acquisition de près de 500 missiles
américain Tomas Hawk alors comment
expliquer ce ce tournant historique au
Japon
aujourd'hui outre la dégradation de
l'environnement de sécurité la guerre en
Ukraine a fait sauter un verrou
psychologique au Japon le risque d'un
conflit de haute intensité est désormais
beaucoup plus tangible et il a fini de
convaincre l'opinion publique nipone de
soutenir un effort significatif de
défense le Premier ministre Kishida a
d'ailleurs martelé dans les instances
internationale que l'Ukraine
d'aujourd'hui pourrait être l'Asie de
l'Est de
demain alors second moyen pour le Japon
de se protéger c'est le renforcement de
son alliance avec les États-Unis c'est
une alliance ancienne résiliante de
moins en moins de moins en moins
asymétrique au fur et à mesure que le
Japon monte en
compétence la problématique du Japon
aujourd'hui est d'assurer la crédibilité
de cette dissuasion et de faire en sorte
que les États-Unis restent bien engagé
en Asie en effet le Japon a bien noté
que la Chine aujourd'hui rattrape les
États-Unis en termees économique
militaire technologique que les
États-Unis depuis l'administration Obama
se monttrre beaucoup plus réticent à
agir comme le gendarme du monde et que
bien entendu depuis l'administration
Donald Trump les États-Unis ont redéfini
leurs intérêts de manière beaucoup plus
étroite America First se désintéressant
du multilatéralisme parfois et att
attaquant même ses leurs alliés au
besoin donc la priorité pour le Japon
c'est de garder les États-Unis engagés
sur le long terme en Asie et engagé pour
la défense du Japon pour cela le Japon
s'est vraiment engagé dans une dans une
approche de dissuasion intégré avec les
États-Unis il a beaucoup investi dans
l'armement américain il l'a toujours
beaucoup fait et ça continue à à à
monter en puissance le Japon va acquérir
une plus d'une centaine de le chasseur
F35 il a transformé plusieurs de ses
portes hélicoptères en porte-avion pour
pouvoir justement accueillir ces F35 et
être complètement interopérable avec les
États-Unis voire l'Australie euh et ce
qu'il fait également c'est qu'il va
chercher à euh intégrer en tout cas
encourager la mise en réseau des alliés
et des partenaires des États-Unis je
pense notamment euh au au dialogue
quadrilatéral dit
quad qui a été relancé en 2017 à
l'initiative du Japon et qui rassemble
donc le Japon les États-Unis mais aussi
l'Inde et l'Australie deux partenaires
essentiels pour
l'Indo-Pacifique en plus de ces efforts
donc pour renforcer sa dissuasion le
Japon développe une stratégie de
Contrepois face à la Chine mais aussi
pour exister finalement dans le contexte
de la rivalité sino
américaine c'est la stratégie pour un
Indo-Pacifique libre et ouvert et cette
stratégie vise originalement à offrir
une vision alternative à celle de la
Chine et de ses routes de la soie il
s'agissait donc d'une réaction face à la
Chine mais aussi d'une réelle tentative
de construire un ordre régional
favorable fondé sur des principes
libéraux État de droit liberté de
navigation avec bien sûr un engagement
américain péren et la mise en place d'un
réseau de partenaires d'affinité pour
faire face à la Chine dans une position
de
force le Japon est aujourd'hui un acteur
essentiel recherché apprécié en
Indo-Pacifique car il se positionne au
cœur d'un ensemble de de
partenaires et d'initiatives varié et
diverses enfin au-delà de
l'Indo-Pacifique le Japon cherche à
développer et approfondir ses
partenariats avec les pays européens
dont la France euh c'est
particulièrement important pour Tokyo
euh parce que cette cette coopération
avec les pays européens lui permet
d'obtenir une une masse critique si on
veut euh face à la Chine et d'agir
notamment euh en matière de
multilatéralisme de de d'État de droit
euh et et d'ordre euh fondé sur des
règles puisque les Européens sont perçus
comme des acteurs en tout cas l'Union
européenne un acteur normatif très
puissant j'en viens à ma ma trè dernière
partie sur la spécificité et la l'avenir
du partenariat franco-japonais dans ce
contexte donc la relation est structurée
autour d'un partenariat d'exception qui
a été lancé en 2013 et et redynamisé en
2023 donc pour la France le Japon c'est
un partenaire important dans
l'Indo-Pacifique d'abord parce qu'il
partage avec elle une définition
géographique très étendue de la zone
Indo-Pacifique qui va vraiment des côtes
orientales euh de l'Afrique au Pacifique
au Pacifique oriental également donc
c'est c'est une définition très large
euh le Japon est donc l'un des
promoteurs le plus actif de cet
Indo-Pacifique libre et ouvert il a une
approche plutôt
inclusive c'est un pôle de stabilité
démocratique en Asie qui est actif dans
les instances multilatérales et qui fait
partie aussi euh des euh la plupart des
initiatives américaines dans la région
donc ça veut dire que le Japon peut
pourrait avoir un un rôle intéressant de
Go bitwin ou d'intermédiaire entre ces
différentes initiatives euh le Japon est
aussi un partenaire qui a des capacités
maritimes intéressantes et qui
permettent de construire une coopération
de bon niveau cette relation bilatérale
c'est progressivement
institutionnalisé nous avons un dialogue
annuel 2+ 2 au niveau ministériel donc
défense et diplomatie depuis 2014 nous
avons un dialogue maritime global un
dialogue sur l'Indo-Pacifique
euh côté coopération de sécurité défense
un accord sur les transferts
d'équipement et une technologie de
défense a été mis en place pour le
développement conjoint d'équipement
notamment de dronees sous-marins pour le
déminage et des accords de soutien
logistique qui permettent de
euh conduire de nombreux exercices
militaires en commun d'abord sur le plan
naval mais aussi ces dernières années
avec les forces aériennes et les forces
terrestres encore très récemment les
armé de terres
donc de de la France et du Japon ont
conduit des exercices en
Nouvelle-Calédonie alors pour autant
euh ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de contrat d'armement
absolument majeur entre la France et le
Japon le Japon reste arrimé aux
États-Unis très fortement pour toutes
les raisons que que j'ai que je j'ai
invoqué même s'il y a des des véités de
de de diversifier euh ses ses
partenaires notamment je pense à
l'accord récent avec le Royaume-Uni et
l'Italie pour développer ensemble un
avion de chasse de nouvell génération
euh et plus globalement euh j'estime
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à une relative
stagnation dans la relation bilatérale
entre la France et le Japon la dernière
feuille de route entre de pour pour pour
pour les années à venir donc
2023-2027 a été adopté assez tardivement
en décembre à l'occasion d'un appel
téléphonique entre les deux chefs d'État
donc de manière assez discrète et donc
sans avancé majeure cela reflète à mon
sens des frustrations de part et
d'autrre que je peux résumer de manière
assez euh simpliste euh côté français le
Japon est souvent considéré comme trop
pantichinois et trop pro américain ou
trop suiveur des des Américains côté
japonais ça va être l'inverse la France
va être considérée comme parfois un peu
trop chinoise et trop
anti-américaine
euh donc côté français euh il y a une y
a une réticence à rentrer dans une
posture trop frontale face à Pékin donc
il y a une une espèce de de de de
prudence euh par rapport à la
communication politique du Japon qui a
tendance à euh à à à baser beaucoup de
choses autour de cette de cette
confrontation avec les avec la Chine eu
côté français il y a un sentiment de
perte de vitesse de la relation
bilatérale par rapport à la la même
relation du Japon avec les États-Unis
bien entendu mais aussi avec l'Australie
euh le Royaume-Uni VO voire même
l'Allemagne plus
récemment et puis certaines frustration
parce que le le Japon fait certes
pression pour que la France s'investisse
davantage en Asie mais souvent il y a
pas vraiment d'attentes précises qui
sont qui sont formulées donc c'est assez
compliqué donc effectivement côté
japonais la France et l'inverse la
France est considérée comme parfois un
peu trop prochinoise anti et
anti-américaine en réalité ça reflète
une confusion autour de la posture
d'autonomie stratégique de la France ou
la la posture de de de puissance
d'équilibre qui est portée par le
Président de la République et cette
confusion qui a été renforcée par les
remarques de du président Macron en 2023
et je pense notamment à son retour de
Chine en avril euh et ses remarques sur
le fait que la France ne serait pas
concernée directement par une crise dans
le détroit de Taïwan et de de
l'importance de ne pas être suiveur des
des États-Unis alors que dans le même
temps une frégate française croisait
dans le détroit de Taïwan
précisément d'autres une autre d'autres
remarques en mai quand le président de
la République s'est opposé publiquement
à l'ouverture d'un bureau de liaison de
l'OTAN à Tokyo donc ces deux remarques
ont provoqué beaucoup d'émotions et des
controverses au Japon euh qui voyait la
France comme particulièrement frileuse
face face à la Chine
alors à mon sens ce sont vraiment des
problèmes de de perception et de posture
et il faut en réalité rétablir certaines
vérité d'abord la stratégie
Indo-Pacifique de la France si elle ne
cible aucun pays et se veut constructive
est largement motivé en réalité par
l'expansion de la Chine et les risques
de déstabilisation dans la région et
cette posture d'équilibre n ne veut pas
dire posture d'équidistance entre les
États-Unis et la Chine et à mon sens
cette cela devrait être beaucoup mieux
assumé euh d'autant plus que si on
regarde effectivement dans la dans la
durée l'alliance entre la France et les
États-Unis est beaucoup plus ancienne et
beaucoup plus forte et solide finalement
que l'alliance entre le Japon et les
États-Unis euh les Américains et les
Français ont combattu ensemble et on a
une coopération opérationnelle complète
euh notamment euh en
Afrique enfin euh le Japon tout comme la
France est un acteur pragmatique qui
cherche à défendre ses intérêts au mieux
et à conserver lui aussi un minimum
d'autonomie sans être complètement
écrasé entre les États-Unis et la
Chine d'ailleurs le Japon est devenu
particulièrement proactif
diplomatiquement notamment sous le
mandat de Donald Trump il a repris à son
compte le grand projet d'accord de libre
échange trans-Pacifique que Donald Trump
avait
abandonné pour le porter et le faire
adopter il s'est aussi détaché de la
ligne américaine pour
euh ne pas soutenir un découplage
économique complet avec la Chine mais
plutôt de soutenir une stratégie qu'on
appelle maintenant en Europe de der
risking avec la Chine et il a continué à
privilégier les forums
multilatéraux je souhaiterais également
rappeler que la stratégie du Japon face
à la Chine n'est pas seulement une
stratégie de dissuasion et de
contre-poids mais qu'elle se base aussi
sur une nécessaire coopération
économique et en cela cette posture
japonaise face à la Chine présente de
nombreuses similitudes avec la PO la
position française et européenne qui
voit la Chine à la fois comme un
partenaire un concurrent et un rival
stratégique donc il me semble que le
Japon et la France et le Japon et
l'Europe plus
généralement peuvent travailler en
étroite
collaboration pour promouvoir auprès de
Washington une approche moins
confrontationnelle et encourager les
solutions multilatérales et cela serait
particulièrement utile dans la
perspective éventuelle d'un second
mandat Trump aux États-Unis donc je vais
terminer sur cette note et je vous
remercie pour votre
attention merci beaucoup madame j'ai une
série de questions s'il a encore des
inscriptions Roger carci qui s'inscrit
jeanluc
cruel
jean-marcous écr pas
viteon je pense qu'on commence par on va
faire une série
de on va faire on va faire par deux je
propose
àuxor de démarrer la
série merci Président Madame votre
intervention tellement complète que vous
avez répondu par anticipation aux
questions que je voulais vous poser mais
je vais quand même vous demander
d'approfondir un sujet que vous avez
évoqué qui est celui de l'opinion
publique japonaise et son impact sur la
stratégie étatique dans un climat un
certain climat de de défiance politique
certaines voix s'élèvent contre
la
remilitarisation par ailleurs la
population de l'archipel de d'Okinawa
qui serait en première ligne en cas de
guerre contre la Chine a réélu en 2022
le gouverneur qui a fait campagne autour
du retrait des bases américaines
pensez-vous qu' un changement de
l'opinion publique s'il se traduit
électoralement pour être remettre en
cause la stratégie actuelle de
contentment chinois et d'alignement sur
les États-Unis je vous
remercie la parole est à Philippe
folot merci madame monsieur le
Président je je voulais vous poser une
une question sur un des éléments et un
des enjeux qui caractérisent le Japon
euh de mémoire et je dis ça parce qu'il
y a une paire d'années j'étais allé dans
l'archipel dans le cadre d'une mission
de de la péotan euh je crois que le
Japon avait 128 millions d'habitants euh
donc aux horizons des années 2010 il
doit y en avoir 125 aujourd'hui et des
prévisions pour 2050 euh amener une
population aux alentours de 80 85
millions d'habitants ou quelque chose
comme ça euh selon vous quelle conséquen
ceci euh aura euh sur euh les enjeux en
matière de sécurité j'allais dire pour
pour pour pour l'archipel y compris en
matière de recrutement euh au niveau des
des des forces armées parce que cette
baisse de population va être la plus
importante que peut-être un pays n'a
jamais connu euh dans l'humanité en
période de paix puisque baisse
démographique mais souvent causé par la
guerre la famine ou ou ou ou d'autres
événements de de de ce type là et et ma
seconde question a trait à locus quelle
est la position du Japon par rapport à à
locus merci Philippe je vous propose de
répondre à ces deux questions et puis
après j'aurai d'autres séries de
questions mercis bien très bien oui
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup pour ces
questions effectivement la question de
de l'opinion publique est
importante longtemps elle a été
plutôt pacifiste antimilitariste et elle
a servi de de Fr si on veut euh à cette
à cet effort de de normalisation
politico-militaire du Japon euh
d'ailleurs quand le le Premier ministre
shinzoabé donc a fait adopter ses
réformes de défense en 2015 on a pu voir
des des
protestations populaires des euh euh des
manifestations dans la rue euh de de de
japonais qui s'inquiétait de cette de de
ce tournant euh pour pour le Japon euh
ce n'a ça n'a pas du tout été le cas
pour ces réformes ces dernières réformes
de décembre 2022 il n'y a pas eu de
protestation majeure bien entendu il y a
l'opinion publique japonaise et et est
plurielle et et diversifié mais il n'y a
pas eu de de de manifestation fortes
comme on a pu le voir en 2015 et ça
c'est vraiment euh ça reflète vraiment
une
évolution de de cette opinion publique
qui est aujourd'hui extrêmement
sensible aux dernières aux dernières
évolutions de sécurité dans la région et
qui a été particulièrement marqué par
cette invasion russe de
l'Ukraine qui a fait un
rapprochement assez rapide avec la
possibilité pour la Chine également de
passer à la action et de pouvoir
éventuellement attaquer
euh taiïwan donc de tout tout à coup
cette
cette ce cette perspective d'avoir
vraiment une un conflit ouvert dans le
voisinage du
Japon a permis
à l'opinion a fait a fait évoluer en
fait l'opinion publique et aujourd'hui
l'opinion publique soutient donc cette
cette cet effort en fait
d'investissement de défense même même si
effectivement ça pose des des
problématiques budgétaires très très
importante de même euh cette l'alliance
avec les États-Unis n'est pas remise en
cause euh bien entendu au niveau local
vous avez raison à Okinawa donc il y a
une pression des bases militaires
locales qui est extrêmement forte euh il
y a eu des crises euh à à répétition
parce qu'il y a eu plusieurs euh
plusieurs
problématiques de de violence contre la
population locale d'
d'accidents qui qui ont mis en cause les
forces
américaines sur sur la population locale
d'Okinawa euh mais pour autant ça n'a
jamais remis en question cette présence
américaine au Japon d'abord pour le le
gouvernement japonais c'est absolument
essentiel ça ça c'est un peu une
garantie en fait hein une une assurance
euh que les Américains vont venir à à la
à la défense du Japon
euh et puis euh pour les les les
Américains c'est aussi une présence
absolument euh essentielle euh on oublie
souvent de de dire que euh le Japon
fournit euh des infrastructures
notamment autour de de Tokyo ayokusuka
qui sont absolument essentiells pour euh
des déployer les capacités navales
américaines en terme de de de de
réparation voilà de de logistique les
les les les les Américains ont aussi
absolument besoin d'avoir d'avoir
ce cet appui au Japon donc pour pour
toutes ces raisons voilà l'opinion
publique japonaise est aujourd'hui
plutôt favorable à cette normalisation
politico-mitaire et à la poursuite de
cette alliance avec les États-Unis
puisque il y a une conscience que le
Japon reste dépendant des États-Unis
h concernant peut-être euh
ocus donc le le Japon a été surpris
comme comme la plupart des
acteurs quand cet accord a été a été
annoncé euh en septembre 2021 euh pour
autant euh le Japon soutient euh ce type
d'initiative puisque ça va ça va
totalement dans le dans dans sa démarche
de de mise en réseau euh des acteurs de
sécurité euh dans la région et et du
fait de d'avoir de pouvoir faire monter
en puissance aussi euh les forces
australiennes qui sont de plus en plus
euh proche et interopérabl avec les
forces japonaises aujourd'hui on parle
d'un d'une quasi alliance en fait entre
entre le Japon et l'Australie et le
Japon compte de plus en plus sur
l'Australie pour venir effectivement de
plus en plus au au nord donc non
seulement en mer de Chine méridionale
mais peut-être en mer de Chine orientale
s'il y avait une crise dans la région eu
on a évoqué à plusieurs reprises des
véités du Japon de rejoindre cet accord
auocus euh rejoindre cet accord ocus sur
son pilier 1
c'est-à-dire de
d'acquisition
d'armement notamment de sous-marins à
propulsion nucléaire ce n'est pas
envisageable pour le Japon aujourd'hui
le Japon reste
absolument hostile à toute forme de
d'acquisition d'une capacité nucléaire
militaire rejoindre au Q sur son pilier
numéro 2 c'est-à-dire participer avec
les États-Unis
euh l'Australie et le
Royaume-Uni à un effort de recherche et
développement et d'innovation dans les
technologies
militaires ce serait
euh je je pense quelque chose qui
serait souhaité par le gouvernement
japonais il y a aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de de limites et d'obstacles qui
euh qui qui ralentissent en fait ce
processus notamment en ce qui concerne
les les protocool
d'échange d'information de renseignement
et de confidentialité des
données voilà pour C les deux questions
merci madame je je il nous reste très
précisément
euh 25 minutes pour les h questions et
après on aura un impératif à MOC parce
qu'on a la présidente du Parlement
chipriote il me reste h questions donc
je vous appelle à la synthèse les uns et
les autres s'il vous plaît donc je passe
à une série de quatre questions d'abord
Catherine
dumin merci monsieur le Président merci
madame je voudrais revenir sur les
relations entre le Japon et la Corée du
Sud euh il y a un contexte historique et
un passé qui pèse lourd entre ceux qu'on
a appelé longtemps les frères ennemis je
voudrais savoir où on en est alors dans
un contexte évidemment de véléité de la
Corée du Nord qui évidemment menace la
paix et la stabilité aussi véléité de la
Chine dans cette région je voudrais
savoir où on en est euh dans le cadre
des des des relations diplomatiques il y
a-t-il un rapprochement y a-t-il une
normalisation de ces relations même si
on sait vous avez parlé de l'opinion
publique japonaise qui est en effet
sensible et par rapport à un certain
nombre de pays vous parliez aussi des
États-Unis euh justement l'opinion
publique japonaise a été très longtemps
très très sensible et réservé à tout
rapprochement
voilà je voudrais savoir où on en est
merci
beaucoup Catherine Pascal Alisa oui
merci monsieur le Président Madame ma
question en fait elle est très très
courte comme l'a demandé le président
qu'en est-il des moyens pour déployer
toutes ces bonnes intentions sont-ils
suffisants bonne question Michel
Grum merci monsieur le Président dans un
rapport du Sénat du 25 janvier 2023 sur
la stratégie française pour l'ardo
Pacifique une proposition avait été
formulée par les sénateurs sur la
cogestion de cette stratégie avec les
territoires ultramarins français un
dialogue devant intervenir en amont de
toute annonce politique concernant la
stratégie
paacifique et l'intégration des
départements région et collectivités
d'outrem à son application un an après
soit ici en janvier 2024 selon votre
point de vue quelles ont été les actions
menées pour
la stratégie o-pacifique et garantir
cette cogestion entre l'État français et
les territoires ultraarins merci merci
Michel pour finir la série Roger carucci
madame est-ce que du fait du principe de
réalité l'alliance
entre le Japon et les États-Unis n'est
pas incontournable est-ce qu'un autre
État peut protéger de manière nucléaire
le Japon non pas plus la France que les
autres bon donc l'alliance américaine
est est absolument nécessaire est-ce
qu'en réalité le Japon n'est pas menacé
même si il se prépare et le point
essentiel reste la revendication
chinoise sur taiïwan parce
qu'historiquement c'est la seule qui est
fondée est-ce que ça plus la dynastie
Kim qui veut faire de la pression sur la
Corée du Sud ce ne sont pas les deux
seuls éléments et est-ce que finalement
sur Taïwan comme sur la Corée en réalité
on peut faire de l'agitation mais est-ce
qu'en réalité l'Union européenne n'est
pas totalement absente pour ne pas dire
inexistante merci Roger madame Pagan je
vous laisse
la merci beaucoup eu alors pour les
relations entre le le Japon et la Corée
du Sud effectivement euh c'est une
relation
complexe sur le papier ce sont deux
démocraties euh ils sont toutes les deux
alliés des États-Unis il y a tout elle
confronte toutes toutes les deux des
défis de taille avec avec la Corée du
Nord mais aussi la Chine et pour autant
les relations loin d'être d'être simple
simple puisqu'elles sont été empoisonné
on va dire par cette héritage historique
qui n'a pas été réglé qui n'a jamais été
réglé avec une longue
colonisation de la péninsule coréenne
par le Japon entre 2010 et 2000 pardon
1910 et et
1945 euh avec des exactions que l'on
connaît avec des problématiques de de
travail forcé de
prostitution pour pour les forces
impériales japonaises et cetera donc t
tous ces dossiersl sont sont sont
toujours euh vivaces donc dans les
opinions publiques euh surtout en Corée
il faut il faut bien le dire euh et ce
sont vraiment des des cartes politiques
qui peuvent être ressortis de manière
régulière réutilisé par par les
gouvernements de par et d'autres
lorsqu'il y a des des tensions euh dans
la relation
euh donc on on peut à mon sens souvent
on parle voilà de des relation de on
compare avec la relation entre entre la
France et l'Allemagne voilà il y avait
quand même des problématique forte et
puis dans l'après-gerre il y a une
réconciliation franco-allemande on on pu
mettre en place
euh la Communauté
européenne je crois qu'il faut plutôt
comparer ses relations aux relations
entre la France et l'Algérie par exemple
pour bien comprendre la la profondeur
des des des problématiques entre entre
les deux pays donc voilà c'est loin
d'être simple
malgré malgré le fait qu'il y a des des
des des valeurs aujourd'hui et des
intérêts en commun il y a toujours ces
problématiques mémorielles qui sont bien
présentes ceci dit effectivement euh
sous l'encouragement ou la pression des
États-Unis surtout qui joue un rôle
assez important qui joue un rôle un peu
de de ciment et qui a encouragé vraiment
vivement ses deux alliés à à se
rapprocher et à travailler ensemble on a
vu ces dernières dizaine d'années des
des véités de de rapprochement et de
coopération notamment au niveau de la
sécurité avec des accords de de partage
de renseignement des mises en place de
d'exercices en commun et cetera alors
souvent ces accords ont été détricotés
euh à la suite d'alternance politique
notamment en Corée puisque en Corée on
sait que l'alternance
politique a des impacts très très forts
en terme de de positionnement de de
politique
étrangère donc aujourd'hui
l'administration youun en Corée qui est
une administration donc conservatrice et
particulièrement
euh proactive en fait pour élargir on va
dire la la l'horizon stratégique de la
Corée du Sud au-delà de la seule
péninsule coréenne parce que jusqu'à
très longtemps c'était quand même le
cas l'administration Yun est très
proactive donc pour un rapprochement
avec le Japon pour un rapprochement plus
globalement avec les États-Unis les
partenaires des États-Unis dans la DO
Pacifique donc la Corée a très récemment
adopté sa propre stratégie indpacifique
ce qui n'était bon donc pas le cas
jusqu'àors et donc on voit une volonté
de mettre de côté ces différents
mémoriels historiques et d'avancer
ensemble sous notamment
l'égide le grand partenaire européen
donc on a pu voir un sommet très
important qui s'est déroulé cet été à
cand David un sommet trilatéral
États-Unis Japon Corée qui a décidé d'
institutionnaliser justement cette cette
relation stratégique de sécurité pour
qu'elle permette de pour lui permettre
de mieux résister à ces à ces
alternances politiques de part et
d'autre donc il y a des rencontres
trilatérales qui vont se faire de
manière annuelle et des manœuvres
communes qui vont monter en puissance et
notamment avec avec des échanges
d'information et encore récemment
lorsque la la Corée la Corée du Nord
donc a procédé à des à des tirs domicile
on a vu l'activation complète de ce
système de partage d'information
trilatéral qui a bien qui a bien
fonctionné donc là on est dans une
dynamique extrêmement positive pour la
relation corée-japon
euh avec une vité de
d'institutionnalisé de l'inscrire dans
la durée mais voilà il faudra voir à
l'avenir ce que nous réserve
l'alternance politique notamment en
Corée du Sud euh conc concernant la
problématique des ressources c'est une
très bonne question et c'est la question
que se pose effectivement le le Japon et
le gouvernement a été prise à parti très
très rapidement sur sur cette
problématique là au départ donc il a dit
voilà on va remettre en place un certain
nombre de de taxes d'impôts sur les
sociétés qui vont nous permettre de
dégager des crédits pour pour alimenter
ce
budget bien entendu il y a eu des
réactions très forte et sagement le
gouvernement a décidé de reporter cette
décision à plus tard euh donc on est
dans un espèce de voilà d'entre deux de
on va on va voir on va en marchant
comment le le gouvernement peut peut
avancer sur ces problématique de
ressources euh on peut garder en tête le
la comparaison avec l'Allemagne où
effectivement bon il y a eu des euh des
annonces très très forte et puis dans un
second temps quelques quelques retour en
arrière dû à un principe de réalité au
niveau au niveau des ressources
publiques donc ça c'est effectivement
c'est c'est ce sont des des des débats
qui vont avoir lieu des débats qui vont
avoir lieu dans le dans le Parlement
dans la sphère publique au Japon dans
les prochaines dans les prochains mois
et dans les prochaines années
h concernant après je je reviendrai tout
à la fin sur sur la stratégie
indopacifique française parce que
finalement c'est c'est un peu une une
question un peu un peu diff
concernant les les menaces vous avez
vous avez tout à fait raison le le le
risque chinois le risque
de d'une invasion chinoise sur taiïwan
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un risque
numéro 1 en réalité parce
que la Chine dispose de tout un tas
d'options en fait de coerition de
pression pour étouffer finalement
taiïwan ou d'essayer de de travailler
sur une une stratégie stgie un peu de la
de la carotte et du bâton à la fois
d'incitation pour essayer de travailler
au corps les forces plutôt favorable à
un rapprochement avec la Chine à Taïwan
par exemple les les l'entreprise les
entrepris le secteur économique donc la
Chine a mis en place des
quelques quelques mesures d'incitation
pour pour attirer les investisseurs
taïwanais sur le continent mais aussi
donc le la politique et surtout en ce
moment la politique du bâton
c'est-à-dire voilà coerition économique
opération d'influence euh
politique chantage euh de ce qu'on
appelle également le le l faire
c'est-à-dire la la guerre par par le
droit donc il y a il y a tout un tas
d'options que la Chine peut utiliser
pour mettre la pression très fortement
sur sur Taïwan sans en arriver à une une
invasion ouverte parce que on considère
que une invasion de Taïwan aujourd'hui
c'est extrêmement compliqué à mettre en
œuvre pour la Chine pour des raisons
d'abord de de géographie c'est très
compliqué de de pouvoir envoyer des
forces navales chinoises traverser le
détroit de taiïwan les eau sont très
euh sont très agité et c'est très
difficile de prendre pied après sur sur
Taïwan euh bon la Chine aussi a a vu
peut-être la le
l'expérience de la Russie en Ukraine qui
pensait euh en quelques jours plier
plier l'affaire et finalement qui se
retrouve sur une sur un conflit de très
longue durée et très complexe à mener
euh et puis un conflit ouvert ce serait
surtout des dégâts extrêmement
importants euh ça veut dire que le la la
Chine rentrerait en guerre non seulement
avec Taïwan mais aussi plus largement
avec avec les États-Unis euh et
potentiellement avec les alliés et
partenaires des États-Unis parce que
bien entendu même si l'OTAN reste une
une alliance transatlantique sur le
théâtre transatlantique ce serait très
compliqué pour des raisons politiques si
les États-Unis étaient d'une manière ou
d'une autre engagé dans un conflit
euh pour ses ses ses alliés et
partenaires de ne pas apporter un
soutien d'une manière ou d'une autre
euh donc effectivement
le les Européens sont
géographiquement éloignés euh du théâtre
asiatique alors comment ils peuvent
peser ils peuvent peser de de
différentes manières d'abord ils peuvent
euh multiplier les efforts pour prévenir
une crise euh dans ce détroit de Taïwan
et c'est euh c'est important c'est
finalement la aujourd'hui la la priorité
c'est de pouvoir euh essayer d'apporter
des éléments assez forts de de dis
ision pour décourager toute aventure
chinoise dans la région de
rappeler l'importance des des principes
de de liberté de navigation et c'est ce
c'est ce à quoi participe et contribue
très activement et très régulièrement la
France puisque la France est l'un des
des des rares pays en
fait à envoyer ses vaisseaux dans le
détroit de Taïwan pour voilà faire
respecter euh le fait que ce des troit
doit rester des EAU internationales
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
utiliser je souhaite rappeler aussi
qu'effectivement en cas de crise dans le
détroit de de taiïwan ça ne concernera
pas seulement l'Asie du Nord-Est le
Taiwan est un acteur absolument
essentiel vraiment crucial dans
l'industrie des semi-conducteurs donc ça
veut dire que l'Union européenne la
France les Européens seraient impacté de
manière absolument
euh très forte en fait par par cette
désorganisation des chaînes de valeur
qui qui impacteraiit toute toute
l'industrie sans compter les la
déstabilisation des des routes maritimes
donc pour pour les questions plus plus
largement commerciales et de énergétique
ce serait ce serait très très complexe
donc nous on a intérêt à soutenir euh
diplom a matiquement Taïwan décourager
les aventures chinoises et puis dans un
second temps s'il y avaitune crise en
fait ouverte qui
se qui qui s'ouvrirait dans la région et
bien les européens peuvent agir de
différentes manières d'abord par
l'imposition de
sanction économique et
politique et puis si on pense aux
capacités militaires et bien les les
Européens sont très engagés dans l'océan
Indien et auraiit un rôle clé à jouer
dans la sécurisation justement de ces
routes maritimes du Moyen-Orient à
l'océan Indien à l'océan Pacifique ces
routes maritimes qui vont dans les deux
sens et qui impacteraiit également la
Chine la Chine est quand même reste
quand même dépendante des des
hydrocarbure du Moyen-Orient donc ça
voudrait dire que que les les les forces
navales europ aurait un rôle important à
jouer aussi dans ce dans ce contexte là
euh maintenant oui madame pour revenir à
votre question sur la stratégie
Indo-Pacifique de la France et
l'acclimatation avec les avec les
territoires
d'outrem je repense peut-être au
déplacement du président de la
République cet été en
Nouvelle-Calédonie donc un point qui
était important à souligner c'est que
pour la première fois dans donc le
président s'est rendu par la suite en
papoisie Nouvelle-Guinée et au vanoitou
et il a été accompagné à ce moment-là du
président de Nouvelle-Calédonie et de la
Polynésie française et ça a été fait
vraiment dans un euh dans une dans dans
l'objectif de d'associer pleinement ces
territoires justement aux démarches de
la France dans la région et à cette
cette stratégie Indo-Pacifique française
dans la région euh maintenant je je
comprends aussi que que la France est
réfléchi à une actualisation de sa
stratégie Indo-Pacifique qui se
fonderait vraiment qui partirait de ces
territoires dans la région parce que
c'est ce qui fait finalement la
légitimité de la France dans la DO
Pacifique c'est qu'elle est une
puissance
résidente de la région et bien entendu
cette cette stratégie doit partir de ces
territoires et doit agir pour ces
territoires et avec ces territoires donc
ça ça va être c'est quelque chose qui
c'est une démarche qui est qui va être
mise mise en
œuvre merci je suis désolé mais je fais
un peu le maître des horloges mais le
temps passe il nous reste très peu de
temps et Catherine dum est allé chercher
la présidente du Parlement chipriote on
a deux questions si vous pouvez faire
vraiment très très rapide il y a
Jean-Luc cruel et Valérie Boyer et puis
donc question rapide une réponse rapide
je suis désoléci président merci donc
Jean-Luc et puis après ok merci beaucoup
he pour cet exposé extrême brillant
extrêmement clair j'avais une question
qui bon qui ne relève pas de c'est bon
vous m'entendez ouais voilà qui ne
relève pas de d'aspect stratégique mais
qui concerne le problème des enfants dit
enlevés dans le cadre de séparation de
conjoints
franco-japonais donc il y a un certain
nombre d'exemples on a un peu de mal à
voir comment faire évoluer cette
situation qui pose des problèmes à pas
mal de Français de l'étranger aller au
Japon après j'avais juste un point
sur la manière dont la France pourrait
jouer en Indo-Pacifique un la France
versus Union européenne un rôle de
puissance d'équilibre compte tenu de la
position de containment de la stratégie
américaine et de la
politique largement d'influence en Asie
avec une initiative visant à étendre la
coopération en matière de sécurité libre
échange avec les pays notamment
l'aséane la France l'Union européenne
ont-ils un rôle à jouer et à affirmer
pour
être facteur d'équilibre merci merci
Valérie merci monsieur le Président je
ma question est est très simple mais
Madame Y a répondu partiellement et je
la remercie c'était pour avoir son
éclairage sur les conséquences des
récentes élections à Tawan justement
sur les relations sino taiwanaises euh
actuel merci merci madame je vous laisse
la parole merci beaucoup euh je vais
beauté en touche sur votre question sur
les enfants enlevés qui est très très
loin de du sujet de de ce jour et qui
est très complexe vous avez raison de de
le soulever mais qui voilà qui qui est
un petit peu au-delà de notre sujet
concernant la la possibilité pour la
France ou l'Union européenne de jouer un
rôle de de dit de puissance d'équilibre
je pense qu'effectivement ce ce terme
prête également à confusion est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment être équilibré la relation
entre les États-Unis et la Chine je
pense que c'est c'est pas de ça dont il
s'agit euh donc au contraire je pense
qu'il faut avoir une approche
pragmatique et se recentrer sur euh les
intérêts de la France dans la région qui
sont numéro 1 la sécurisation de nos
territoires dans la région euh
ensuite assurer la stabilité de la
région et dans ce cadre on a tout
intérêt à essayer de modérer le plus
possible atténuer le plus possible cette
rivalité euh sino-américaine qui prend
un tour idéologique et qui force nombre
de pays de la région à choisir un camp
quelque part alors que il y a beaucoup
de pays qui qui travaillent avec avec
avec ces deux acteurs et donc dans ce
sens la France l'approche française est
une approche inclusive donc elle ne
s'interdit pas de travailler avec la
Chine quand il le faut elle reconnaît
l'importance de la Chine quand il le
faut mais c'est aussi un allié
absolument essentiel euh des États-Unis
donc c approche inclusive permet
justement
d'offrir plus d'options voilà une une
alternative en plus aux pays de la
région et de ne pas les contraindre en
fait à faire un choix entre un
camp américain ou un camp
chinois en ce qui concerne les élections
à Taïwan effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on
peut attendre donc c'est un c'est un
candidat qui soutient une ligne alors je
dirais qui soutient plutôt que
l'indépendance qui soutient le statut
quo
aujourd'hui il y a pas vraiment de de
véidité d'indépendance du côté du côté
de de taiïwan
aujourd'hui pour autant c'est un c'est
un parti qui prône
effectivement une certaine plus
d'autonomie et d'avoir une envergure
pour pour Taïwan plus plus importante
donc c'est sans doute cela va provoquer
sans douteavant age de de remou dans le
détroit de Taïwan dans les prochains
dans les prochains mois on peut
s'attendre à des à des
réactions qui ont déjà d'ailleurs été
exprimés de la part de de la Chine
puisque c'est quand même c'est toute la
troisème fois en fait que que ce parti
démocrate donc
autonomiste gagne des élections à
taiïwan ce qui montre bien que le le le
le la tendance en fait à Taiwan n'est
pas en tout cas vers un un rapprochement
un possible rapprochement politique avec
la Chine dans euh dans l'immédiat voilà
donc on peut on peut sans doute
s'attendre à davantage de remous dans
les prochains
mois merci merci beaucoup madame merci
pour ces éclaircissements et je pense
que compte tenu des enjeux dans la
région et que vous avez remarquablement
abordé qui ne manque pas évidemment de
nous inquiéter j'imagine le travail à
venir de notre commission
va notamment nous amener à vous
retrouver j'imagine pour des auditions
complémentaires de et et donc le le
travail
d'une d'une mission complémentaire
j'allais dire sur notre rapport
indopacifique qui s'est déroulé l'an
dernier prend tout son sens donc ce sera
ce sera je pense passionnant mais merci
pour ces pour ces échanges et puis nous
nous je pense nous nous retrouverons ou
si ce n'est pas nous à minima les
rapporteurs de et les les et les
commissaires qui seront dans la mission
Japon très prochainement donc merci
beaucoup pour cette cette brillante
explication et je vous propose de passer
à la suite mes chers collègues on va
accueillir donc madame la présidente du
Parlement
chipriote merci
beaucoup